well I learned that you have to be very
smart and hardworking to be poor and
unemployed in in the US because the
systems are so incredibly complex and
they come from a wide variety of sources
and they're based on different metrics
and uh they then are also um discounted
or and lost at various points when you
make more of an income than you used to
so what they told me is that it feels
hopeless it feels like there's nothing
they can do to change their their
situation uh one of them told me that
doing the calculations from four
different benefit systems if she
increases her wage from 29,000 to 30,000
so many of the benefits full away so
that she just makes 15,000 half of it so
it means that the in a way the marginal
tax rate for the poor and unemployed is
much higher than for the rich